you and not just phase four but other
phases as well we've kicked off a new
saga the first 11 years of the MC were
called the infinity saga and now we are
in a new saga and these next 10 years
are going to be absolutely incredible
with the introduction of the Fox
characters that Disney now owns such as
the Fantastic Four the x-men Doctor Doom
the Silver Surfer Galactus
and more and with all these new amazing
characters that Disney can now use in
the MCU the question is when exactly are
we going to see them appear well it
looks like we could be seeing our first
x-men in Black Widow briefly but then we
could see a full-out reveal of one
specific X Men in Black Panther 2 we've
had a lot of leaks about black panther 2
recently one of which is that Doctor
Doom is going to be the main villain of
the film and recently in another plot
leaked it offers a way that Doctor Doom
could be introduced to Black Panther 2
and how another x-men could be
introduced in black panther 2 as well
and this actually ties into a theory
that I had over a year ago about how
they could introduce the x-men in the
MCU so I'll break this all down in this
video I'm still doing my Xbox one and
ps4 giveaway all you have to do to enter
is be subscribed with notifications
turned on like this video and leave a
comment down below so of course as many
people know by now Charles Murphy has
said that Doctor Doom is going to be the
main villain of black panther 2 this is
super exciting and it kind of makes a
lot of sense that they wouldn't
introduce Doctor Doom in the Fantastic
Four because that's been done before and
it's been done before by Fox and Marvel
is going to want to stay as far away as
the Fox versions of the Fantastic Four
as possible and not just Fox's version
of the Fantastic Four but Fox's version
of the x-men as well that means not
introducing Doctor Doom in a Fantastic
Four movie and not introducing the x-men
all together in one giant movie so
according to Charles Murphy in some
other leaks as well Doctor Doom is going
to be making his MCU debut in black
panther 2 according to some recent links
he is going to be looking for of course
vibranium the leak says that he needs
vibranium for some very big purpose and
he's going to have a very strong and
very similar backstory to Thanos and
that's really good because there's a
reason that Thanos as many people's
favorite villain
in the MCU he's not evil just for the
sake of being evil
he has a really strong back story about
his planet dying his people dying so now
he's set off to save the universe now
unfortunately that meant killing half of
the universe but to himself he was a
hero not a villain
so it looks like dr. doom is going to
have somewhat of a similar story and
you've heard me say this before but it's
been said by multiple insiders that
there are going to be two main villains
of the MCU there's going to be a ground
/ earth villain which is going to be
Doctor Doom and then there's going to be
a cosmic villain which is said to be
Galactus so dr. doom is supposed to be
set up as a villain that's going to be
around for the next ten years so of
course he's going to need a very good
and very strong backstory and as it
turns out there have been little
remnants of him in Phase three this
league states that it was actually
Victor Von Doom who wanted Hank Pym slap
an ant-man and the wasp son Ebert was
working for Victor Von Doom the whole
entire time and I'm sure as they
revealed these Fox characters they'll
also reveal and try to tie in where
they've been this whole entire time
during the infinity saga in fact we know
that that's what they're going to be
doing with the Eternals the Eternals are
thousands and thousands of years old and
the Eternals are actually supposed to
protect earth and the humans so a lot of
people were wondering where exactly were
the Eternals when Thanos came and Kevin
Feige has already confirmed that the
Eternals know who the Avengers are but
the Avengers do not know who the
Eternals are so of course in the movie
they're going to reveal where exactly
the Eternals were when Thanos came and
when Ultron came and when Loki came with
Thanos's army in the first Avengers
movie they'll do this for all of the Fox
characters as well it's the Marvel
Cinematic Universe everything is
connected so of course they'll reveal
where the x-men were this whole entire
time and that brings us to this plot
leaked that states that storm is going
to be introduced in black panther 2 now
if you know anything about the
relationship between Black Panther and
storm this makes perfect sense and the
comics not only have storm and black
panther known each other for a very long
time but they were also married for
about five years yes T'Challa and Aurora
were married and it was an extremely big
deal Black Panther and storm first met
when they were children
storms parents were killed in Cairo and
she was left alone in the desert storm
was heading back to Kenya to look for
her mother's homeland when she came
across Black Panther being kidnapped
storm had recently developed her weather
controlling powers and she used these
powers to save Black Panther the two of
them hit it off instantly and remained
best friends for a very long time until
eventually Black Panther went on to join
the Avengers and then storm went on to
join the x-men after being separated for
a while two chala
eventually decided that it was time for
him to get married and Black Panther vol
4 number 14 and 15 black panther
proposes to storm and eventually after
saying no she says yes the two of them
got married in their wedding was
possibly one of the biggest events of
comic book history it happens in Black
Panther vol 4 number 18 and it takes
place during the Civil War ceasefire
event the event was so big that most of
the x-men and most of the Avengers
showed up even though they were at odds
over the superhuman Registration Act the
wedding was so big that The Watcher
himself even showed up to witness this
event between a powerful mutant and an
Avenger and a king so it was a very big
deal but unfortunately it only lasted
about six years and one of the biggest
events in Marvel history The Avengers
versus the x-men Black Panther and storm
found themselves on opposite sides
obviously black panther being an Avenger
and storm being an x-men during this
event the Phoenix force came back to
earth and it possessed many people
including name war and Namor let his
Atlantean people into battle against
Wakanda the fallout from this event was
severely catastrophic the Avengers were
left scattered and the damage done to
Wakanda was extremely severe and black
panther blamed storm for siding with the
x-men and not the Avengers and himself
so after the event he got his marriage
annulled and ever since then the two of
them have not been together so as you
can see there is a lot of history
between Black Panther and storm in the
comics so it wouldn't make sense that
they would introduce her in Black
Panther 2 now of course they never go
the exact same route that they do in the
comics in the movies so they may not get
married after all at the end of Black
Panther T'Challa was with Nakia but we
didn't see her anywhere in of the
infinity war and Avengers in game but
perhaps she'll return in black panther 2
but as far as storm is concerned she
could be with a different tribe just
like mbaku has his white gorilla cult
she could be somewhere else in Wakanda
and the reason that she could be brought
into black panther 2 is because Doctor
Doom is such a powerful villain
especially if he gets his hands on some
vibranium which I'm sure he will I'm
sure that's what his mask is going to be
made out of and of course depending on
the route that Marvel goes there's the
possibility that it could get infused
with his body and if that's the case
what Conda is going to need all the help
that it could get and all tribes are
going to have to come together to fight
against Doctor Doom so we could have a
situation that is almost exactly like
Avengers infinity war here T'Challa gets
all of the help that he can get to stand
up against Thanos and his army he even
goes and asked for the help of mbaku
and two challahs people and in Bacchus
people stand against Thanos his army we
could see this happen again but with dr.
doom instead of Thanos only this time
black panther's army and in Bacchus army
may not be enough so what could he do
well he could go and seek the help of
his childhood friend who he knows has
super powers because although they
probably won't explore the marriage
aspect from the comics and the movies
they'll probably keep the fact that they
were good childhood friends the same and
she could also be really good friends
with Sheree there really are a lot of
ways to introduce storm in Black Panther
2 which seems to be the route that
they're going to go down and if this is
the case we are leading up to a major
cinematic event in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe the Avengers versus the x-men
now this is something that is kind of
inevitable to happen now it won't happen
anytime soon because of course first
Marvel has to introduce the x-men to the
MCU not to mention we have to get a new
Avengers team so sadly it probably won't
happen until another 10 years but it can
be set up within these next 10 years
when the x-men come into the MCU they
may not get along with the Avengers too
well and this is an event that Marvel
knows could be absolutely massive even
way bigger than Avengers endgame and
with Kevin feige's announcement at San
Diego comic-con that the x-men / mutants
are coming to the MCU you know that they
are thinking about it Marvel thinks
years and years ahead and ties
everything together and you know that
they have to figure out a way to outdo
Avengers and
since it was such a massive success well
an Avengers versus the x-men movie is
certainly a great way to do that but
before that happens of course they have
to introduce the x-men in the MCU now if
you cut my other video about the black
widow trailer it looks like there could
be a mutant introduced in Black Widow
there's strong evidence of Ursa Major a
mutant being in the movie and if that's
the case Black Widow is going to be the
first time that we see an x-men in the
MCU and that's just next year now
that'll be just a little bit of a tease
they probably won't use the word mutant
they probably won't use the word x-men
but black panther 2 already has a
release date said to come out in may
2022 in phase 5
so black panther 2 comes out two years
after Black Widow comes out that's
plenty of time for more mutant Easter
eggs to be dropped in the MCU and then
the introduction of them with storm in
black panther 2 now of course there is
obviously the possibility that they
could introduce other mutants into the
MCU during other times but given the
history of storm and black panthers
relationship in the comics and given how
much of a success black panther 1 was
having the first really known main x-men
appear in black panther 2 makes perfect
sense there will be a ton of hype around
the movie and it will be a seamless
introduction and although of course this
is not officially confirmed yet it seems
like a route that Marvel is likely to go
and if this route ends up being true
storm and the x-men will be introduced
in black panther 2 so things are getting
really exciting let me know what you
think about this do you think it's a
good idea to introduce storm in black
panther to let me know your thoughts in
the comments down below and also don't
forget to subscribe with notifications
turned on and like the video so you can
enter my giveaway for a chance to win an
Xbox one or a ps4 the winner gets to
choose also don't forget to use code
cosmic at G fuel comm for 30% off G fuel
also click the link in the description
down below for your chance to win an
Infinity Gauntlet as always thank you
all so much for watching
woof woof